en excellence
j'ai le grand plaisir de souhaiter la
bienvenue à son excellence monsieur
naftali bennet premier ministre ministre
des affaires communautaires et ministre
des affaires numériques national
de l'état d'israël je l'invite à prendre
la parole devant l'assemblée générale
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les représentantes
et représentants
israël est un phare dans une mer agitée
un bastion de démocratie
divers dans sa conception innovant de
par sa nature
désireux que tous de contribuer à la vie
du monde bien que se trouvant dans la
région la plus dure qui soit sur terre
nous sommes une nation ancienne
retourner vers son ancienne patrie
qui a relancé sa langue ancienne
et retrouver
sa souveraineté ancien israël est un
miracle du renouveau juif
am israel rail nation d'israël est
vivante et l'état d'israël en est le
coeur battant mes amis
bien trop longtemps israël a été défini
par les guerres avec ses voisins
or ce n'est pas cela qui définit israël
ce n'est pas ce qui définit le peuple
d'israël
voyez vous les israéliens à israël ne se
réveille pas le matin en pensant aux
conflits les raillaient les israéliens
comme chacun chacune veulent vivre une
vie de qualité s'occuper de leur famille
bâtir un monde meilleur pour leurs
enfants
ce qui signifie que de temps à autre
il nous faut parfois quitter nos emplois
à dire au revoir à nos familles
pour nous rendre sur le champ de
bataille afin d'y défendre notre pays
tout comme mes amis et moi-même avons dû
le faire parfois
ils et elles ne devraient pas être jugé
à l'aune de cette action
les israéliens se souviennent des
horreurs du passé mais sont déterminés à
rester tourner vers l'avenir et faire
advenir un avenir plus brillant
nommé messieurs les représentantes et
représentants
deux fléaux
frappe actuellement le tissu même de
notre société
l'un bien entendu et le choral à dieuze
qui a tué plus de cinq millions de
personnes de par le monde
l'autre
a aussi ébranlé le monde tel que nous le
connaissons je veux parler de la maladie
de la polarisation politique
tant le coronavirus que la polarisation
peuvent ronger la confiance du public
dans nos institutions tous deux peuvent
paralyser les nations
en l'absence de mesures leurs effets
contre la société peuvent être des
vastes heures
en israël nous sommes confrontés à ces
deux mots
plutôt que de les accepter comme force
de la nature et bien nous nous sommes
levés nous avons agi et aujourd'hui un
nouvel horizon se dessine déjà dans un
monde polarisé où les algorithmes
alimente la haine les individus de
droite et de gauche opèrent dans deux
réalités deux mondes distincts chacun
dans sa petite bulle des réseaux sociaux
n'entendons que les voix qui viennent
qu'on ferme is confirmé ce en quoi il
croit déjà
et puis les gens se retrouvent à
assaillir les uns les autres
les sociétés se déchirent
parce que personne ne s'écoutent plus
nos pays brisées de l'intérieur
nous peuvent aller nulle part israël
après quatre élections en l'espace de
deux ans avec une 5e qui se dessine à
l'horizon
eh bien les la population appelée à cor
et à cri un antidote le cadenas
stabilité une tentative digne de ce nom
de parvenir à une normalité politique
voyez-vous
l'inertie est toujours le choix le plus
facile mais parfois
les dirigeants doivent
prendre la barre avant
d'arriver au bout de la falaise faire
face aux difficultés pour mener leur
pays à la sécurité voilà ce que nous
avons fait il ya environ 100 jours des
partenaires et moi même avons ou
constituer un nouveau gouvernement en
israël le gouvernement le plus divers de
l'histoire d'israël
ce qui avait commencé comme un accident
politique
peut aujourd'hui devenir un réel but ce
but c'est l'unité
aujourd'hui nous sommes assis tous et
tout autour d'une même table nous nous
parlons avec respect nous agissons avec
décence nous sommes porteurs d'un
message
les choses peuvent changer
bien que nous ayons des opinions
politiques très divergentes nous sommes
là pour le bien de notre nation ce n'est
pas un problème que de ne pas être
d'accord je dirais même que il est vital
que nous ayons des pensées différentes
ce n'est pas non plus un problème que de
débattre
un des bassins est un précepte de base
de la tradition juif je peux vous dire
aussi que c'est un des secrets
du succès de cette jeune nation
dans les entreprises vous constaterez
que ce débat est là bien vivant car il
est au coeur de l'innovation
nous avons à présent prouver en israël
que même à l'ère des médias sociaux nous
pouvons débattre
sans haine
cette seconde grande maladie à laquelle
nous sommes tous confrontés est celle du
choral à des russes ce qui a balayé le
monde pour en venir à bout
il va nous falloir faire de nouvelles
découvertes
apprendre des choses nouvelles parvenir
à de nouvelles percées
tout commence par la quête de savoir
l état d'israël est en première ligne
en ce qui concerne cette quête d'un
savoir vital nous avons en israël
élaborer un modèle
lequel conjugue la sagesse des
scientifiques et le pouvoir des
décideurs politiques
le modèle israélien repose sur trois
principes directeurs premièrement le
pays doit rester ouvert
nous avons tous payé un lourd tribut un
tribut économiques physiques émotionnels
interrogé simplement vos enfants
après que la vie se soit arrêtée en 2020
mes chers amis
pour ramener les économies sur le chemin
de la croissance
ramener les enfants sur le chemin de
l'école et ramener les parents sur le
chemin de leurs trois travail et bien
les confinements les restrictions les
quarantaines
ne sont pas la solution ils ne sont pas
tenables à long terme
notre modèle plutôt que d'enfermer les
gens
les réduire à des acteurs passifs nous
les associons aux efforts que nous
déployons un exemple nous avons demandé
aux familles israéliennes
de
tester leurs enfants chez eux pour
pouvoir garder les écoles ouvertes et
les écoles sont restées ouvertes
aujourd'hui je puis vous dire que
nous avons distribué des douzaines de
ces auto test aux parents israéliens ils
peuvent être associés à la lutte
deuxième règle vacciner le plus tôt
possible dès le début israël et israël
ont été rapides rapidement à choisir le
vaccin nous sommes dans une course
contre un virus mortel nous devons
rester en tête en juillet nous avons été
les premiers à nous rendre compte que là
le vaccin s'affaiblissait d'où la
flambée de cas du variant dé le tarn
israël c'est alors que mon gouvernement
a décidé d'administrer les troisièmes
doses de vaccin rappelle au public en
israël la décision a été difficile étant
donné qu'à l'époque la f10 et l'avait
même pas encore à prouver
mais nous avons été confrontés à un
choix
soit entraînée israël dans un nouveau
cycle de confinement préjudiciable à
notre économie à la société soit faire
le pari des vaccins nous avons fait ce
choix israël a été pionnier en matière
de rappels
deux mois plus tard je puis vous dire
que cela fonctionne avec une troisième
dose
vous obtenez cette fois plus de
protection qu'avec deux doses huit mois
plus tard et vous êtes 40 fois plus
protégés que 100 le vaccin
la dose de rappel fonctionne c'est ainsi
qu' israël est en passe d'échapper à la
quatrième vague sans savoir dû recourir
au confinement sans nouveaux dommages à
notre économie l'économie israélienne
est en hausse le chômage est en baisse
je suis heureux que nos actes est
inspiré d'autres pays à faire de même et
opter pour un rappel troisième règle
l'adaptation est l'action rapide nous
avons constitué une équipe spéciale
nationale qui se réunit chaque jour je
la dirigeais cette équipe spéciale vise
à contourner cette lenteur
bureaucratique que nous connaissons à
poser des actions rapides
et à réagir immédiatement
les essais sont la clé
chaque jour est un jour nouveau qui
s'accompagnent de nouvelles données de
nouvelles décisions lorsque quelque
chose il faut quelque chose fonctionne
nous le maintenons lorsque ça ne
fonctionne pas nous les cartons et nous
passons à autre chose
mes amis diriger un pays pendant une
pandémie
n'est pas simplement une question de
santé il s'agit de jongler avec soin
avec tous les aspects de la vie qui sont
affectés par le corona notamment
l'emploi l'éducation
si les médecins sont extrêmement
importants ils ne peuvent pas
e piloter les et les sit in national la
seule personne qui
se trouve dans une situation avantageuse
est capable de jongler entre tous et le
dirigeant du pays nous faisons
actuellement tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour donner à la population les
outils dont elle a besoin pour se
protéger
le texte ancien des juifs le talmud nous
dit que
quiconque sauve une vie sauve
l'humanité tout entière
voilà ce à quoi nous aspirons
m haies messieurs les représentantes et
représentants
alors qu israël s'efforce de faire le
bien nous ne pouvons pas un instant
perdre de vue ce qu'il se passe dans
notre région israël est littéralement
entouré par le hezbollah les milices
chiites le djihad islamiste et la
ramasse
il se trouve à nos frontières
ces groupes terroristes visent à dominer
le moyen-orient à propager l'islam
radical dans le monde entier
qu'ont ils tous en commun
tous veulent détruire mon pays
et tous sont soutenus par l'iran
ils obtiennent leur financement de léran
les obtiennent leur formation de l'iran
ils guettent là ils obtiennent leurs
armes de l'iran
l'objectif ultime de l'iran est on ne
peut plus clair pour quiconque prend la
peine d'ouvrir les yeux
l'iran veut dominer la région
et veut le faire
sous un parapluie nucléaire
depuis 30 ans l'iran a semé la
destruction
sans des carnages au moyen-orient pays
après pays au liban en irak en syrie au
yémen
et à gaza
compte en commun tous ces lieux eh bien
ils sont en déliquescence leurs citoyens
enfin et souffre leur économie
s'effondre
un peu comme midas on peut dire que le
régime iranien
à la touche du maule à chaque endroit
que l'iran touche
s'effondre
et si vous pensez que la terreur
iranienne se limite en israël vous avez
tort
permettez moi de vous annoncer quelque
chose cette année
l'iran
a rendu opérationnel une nouvelle unité
de terroristes d armée de drones tueurs
armés d'armes mortelles capable de
d'attaqué quelques endroits que ce soit
à tout moment leur objectif est de se
propager dans les ciels dans le ciel du
moyen-orient de déployer cette force
mortelle ils l'ont déjà fait avec le
char à 836 qu'à attaquer l'arabie
saoudite des cibles américaines en irak
les navires civils en mer et récemment
encore ils ont tué un britannique et à
romain l'iran à l'intention d'ares mais
c'est branche du yémen de l'irak du de
la syrie du liban
leur fournissons des centaines voire à
terme des milliers de ces drones
mortelle alors vous pouvez
l'ignorer mais l'expérience nous a
montré que ceux qui commencent au
moyen-orient
se propage un jour ou l'autre
mesdames et messieurs les représentantes
et représentants en 1988 l'iran a
constitué une commission de la mort car
ordonné l'assassinât en masse de 5000
militants politiques
ils ont été pendues depuis des grues
cette commission de la mort se composait
de 4 personnes
ebrahim raïssi nouveau président de
l'iran où il en faisait partie
raïssi a aussi supervisé l'assassinât
d'enfants iranien
son surnom est le boucher de téhéran
parce que c'est exactement ce qu'il a
fait il a massacré son propre peuple
un des témoins de ce massacre a déclaré
dans son témoignage
que lorsque raïssi
achever d'assassiner certaines personnes
ils organisaient une fête
empochant l'argent de ceux et celles
qu'il venait d'exécuter ensuite
il s'asseyait à table pour y déguster
des gâteaux à la crème
célébrant l'assassinât de son propre
peuple
à grand renfort de gâteaux à la crème
ce même raïssi
est aujourd'hui président de l'iran
voilà à qui nous avons affaire
ces dernières années l'iran a fait un
bond en avant dans le cadre de son
problème programme de recherche
développement nucléaire de sa capacité
de production et d'enrichissement
le programme d'armes nucléaires iraniens
arrive un tournant
toutes les lignes rouges ont été
franchies les inspections ont été
ignorés
tout ce que l'on espérait s'est avéré
faux il rend violent actuellement
l'accord sur les garanties de l'aiea et
il s'en tire sans souci ils harcèlent
les inspecteurs sabote leur enquête et
ils s'en tirent ils enrichissent de
l'uranium
à hauteur de 60%
pour ainsi dire suffisant pour produire
des armes et ils s'en sortent
les données qui prouvent très clairement
les intentions iraniennes en matière
d'armes nucléaires l'essec les sites
secrets de turku zaba de téhéran et de
marie van tout cela est simplement
ignoré
le programme nucléaire iranien
a atteint un moment crucial
il en va de même de notre tolérance
et belles paroles
ne stoppe pas les centrifugeuses
elle ne les empêche pas en pêche pas de
tourner dos cas dans le monde souhaite
voir dans la
quête de l'iran d'armes nucléaires une
réalité inévitable où ils sont
simplement là d'en entendre parler
israël n'a pas ce privilège
nous ne peuvent nous ne pouvons pas nous
lasser nous ne nous lasserons nous ne
nous lasserons jamais nous ne
permettrons pas à l'iran d'acquérir une
arme nucléaire j'aimerais vous dire
quelque chose
l'iran est bien plus faible
bien plus
vulnérables qu'il n'y paraît
son économie est en déroute son régime
est pourri
divorcé de la jeune génération iranienne
son gouvernement corrompu
ne parvient même pas
approvisionnée en eau nos deux vastes
pans du pays
plus l'iran s'affaiblit
plus il va loin pour cacher ses
faiblesses
et je vous le dis si nous y
réfléchissons si nous voulons vraiment
les arrêter si nous utilisons notre
inventivité nous pourrons l'emporter
c'est exactement ce que nous allons
faire
mes chers amis
tout n'est pas aussi sombre au
moyen-orient outre ces tendances
inquiétantes ou constatons des lueurs
d'espoir avant tout et surtout les liens
toujours plus fort que forget israël
avec des pays arabes et musulmans
ces liens qui ont commencé à être d'ici
dix à quarante deux ans avec l'accord de
paix historique de d'israël avec
l'egypte qui se sont poursuivies il ya
27 ans avec l'accord de paix signé avec
la jordanie et plus récemment avec les
accords d'abraham qui ont normalisé nos
relations avec les émirats arabes unis
le bahreïn et le maroc
mais ce n'est pas fini
au jeune âge de 73 ans de plus en plus
de nations
aulas l'âge pardon de la maturité de
73,1 de plus en plus de nations
comprennent la valeur et la place unique
d'israël dans le monde certains amis
sont à nos côtés depuis notre création
les etats unis d'amérique
sont un ami de longue date un allié de
confiance d'israël comme nous l'avons vu
une fois encore il ya quelques jours au
congrès
aux côtés de nos amis de longue date
nous faisons de nouveaux amis au
moyen-orient et au-delà la semaine
dernière nous avons vu
la défaite de la conférence de durban
racistes et antisémites cette conférence
initialement visait à lutter contre le
racisme et au fil des ans elle est
devenue une conférence du racisme contre
israël et le peuple juif
le monde en a assez
je tiens à remercier les 38 pays 38 qui
ont choisi la vérité plutôt que le
mensonge et ont
renoncé à la conférence
aux pays qui ont choisi
de participer à cette farce je ne puis
que dire que attaquer israël ne vous
rend pas supérieur moralement
lutter contre la seule démocratie du
moyen-orient
ne
vous rend pas
à la mode
adopté les clichés contre israël sans
prendre la peine de vous informer
bien c'est simplement de la paresse
chers amis chaque état membre ici à un
choix
c'est pas un choix politique
un choix moral à faire le choix entre
les ténèbres et la lumière
des ténèbres de persécution des
prisonniers politiques
ténèbres qui assassinent des innocents
abusent des femmes des minorités
s'efforce de mettre un terme au mode
moderne tel que nous le connaissons ou
la lumière lumière de liberté de
prospérité
d'opportunités
ses 73 dernières années l'état d'israël
et le peuple d'israël
a tant fait
en dépit des difficultés et pourtant
je puis vous le dire avec confiance
le meilleur est devant nous
israël est une nation pétri d'espoir une
nation qui a ramené à la vie et
l'héritage la torah dans l'israël
moderne une nation dont l'esprit est
irréductible
mais at me now d'ouvrir albé in a row
cher
une lueur d'espoir
dicible dissipe les ténèbres
le phare dans la mer agitée se tient
fort au
sa lumière est plus vive que jamais je
vous remercie
au nom de l'assemblée générale je tiens
à remercier le premier ministre ni aux
affaires communautaires et ministre des
affaires numériques national de l'état
d'israël de l'allocution qu'il vient de
prononcer et je prie le protocole de
bien vouloir accompagner son excellence